chapeau lunettes de soleil parasol je
suis prêt pour un bon bain de soleil ah
j'allais oublier la crème solaire même à
l'ombre elle est utile ça nous est
toutes et tous arrivé un jour ou l'autre
un coup de soleil ça fait mal et c'est
pas très bon pour notre santé
aujourd'hui je vous explique pourquoi on
attrape un coup de soleil commençant
protéger à quoi correspondent les
chiffres sur les flacons de crème
solaire et pourquoi nous ne sommes pas
tous aussi sensibles au soleil
[Musique]
le soleil émet de la lumière de la
lumière visible les fameuses couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel mais pas seulement une
partie de son rayonnement échappe à
notre regard nos yeux n'y sont pas
sensibles
heureusement une grande partie d'entre
eux est arrêtée par la couche d'ozone
mais pas les idées A et B ce sont eux
qui peuvent faire du tort à notre peau
voici une maquette représentant la peau
en coupe avec ses trois couches
l'hypoderme
le derme et au dessus
l'épiderme oui je sais sa chatouille les
UVB pénètrent dans la couche
superficielle de la peau l'épiderme
jusqu'à la couche basale située à
l'interface d'herme épidermes où se
trouve les cellules souches de la peau
c'est cette couche qui en se régénérant
permet à la peau de se renouveler en
permanence le problème c'est que les UVB
pénètrent au cœur des cellules et
atteignent l'ADN contenu dans leur noyau
or une fois l'ADN touchée les cellules
ne fonctionnent plus correctement elles
peuvent même dégénérer notre organisme
choisit alors de s'en débarrasser à ce
moment-là la flux sanguin augmente pour
que les globules blancs fassent le
ménage les vaisseaux s'élargissent c'est
la réaction inflammatoire et c'est bien
parce que les vaisseaux se dilatent pour
laisser passer davantage de sang que la
peau rougit et que l'on éprouve une
sensation de chaleur et de douleur
ah c'est sûr je mets plus le nez dehors
heureusement ça ne se passe pas tout le
temps comme ça uniquement lorsque l'on
s'expose sans prendre garde
il est hors de question de se passer
complètement de soleil notre organisme a
besoin de lumière elle régule notre
horloge biologique notre humeur elle
active la production de vitamine D celle
que l'on surnomme la vitamine du soleil
nos eaux en ont besoin pour fixer les
calcium et elle stimule aussi notre
système immunitaire nous devons donc
apprendre à vivre avec le soleil
heureusement notre peau dispose de
système de défense naturelle contre les
UVB
la couche cornée d'abord une couverture
constituée de cellules de peau morte qui
agit comme un film protecteur elle
renvoie une partie des UVB plus on
s'expose au soleil plus cette couche
s'épaissit et ce n'est pas tout plus en
profondeur elle ADN au niveau de chaque
cellule est protégé par des pigments la
mélanine la peau contient plus ou moins
selon qu'elle est claire ou foncée la
mélanine agit comme un bouclier en
absorbant les UVB elle est produite par
des cellules spécialisées les
mélanocytes plus il y a de soleil plus
les mélanocytes produisent de mélanine
il faut 48 heures pour que le processus
se mette en place c'est pourquoi il est
recommandé de s'exposer au soleil
graduellement quand on part en vacances
quelques minutes au départ puis un peu
plus chaque jour et peu à peu la peau
prend des couleurs en effet quand une
cellule de peau meurt elle est poussée
vers la surface
transportant la mélanine qu'elle
contient plus on s'exposent au soleil
plus les cellules qui s'empilent dans
l'épiderme contiennent donc de la
mélanine et plus on est bronzée ceci
explique aussi qu'une fois l'été passé
le bronzage disparaît les cellules qui
contiennent beaucoup de mélanine comme
toutes les cellules arrive à la surface
de l'épiderme et elle disparaissent la
peau d'escouade comme l'on dit comme il
y a moins de soleil elles sont petit à
petit remplacées par des cellules qui
contiennent moins de mélanine mais alors
s'il faut s'exposer pour produire de la
mélanine et que la mélanine nous protège
du soleil à quoi ça sert de se
badigeonner de crème tout pouvait pas me
le dire plus tôt parce que la mélanine
ne fait pas tout d'abord parce qu'en
fonction de notre pigmentation nous en
produisons plus ou moins moi par exemple
qui est la peau claire j'en produit peu
moins que Teddy Riner Will Smith donc le
bouclier n'a pas toujours la même
efficacité du coup il y en a qui peuvent
se passer de crème solaire pas du tout
car si la mélanine protège assez
efficacement contre les UVB elle laisse
passer un autre type d'ultraviolet les
UV a souvenez-vous eux aussi arrivent
jusqu'à nous ceci pénètre encore plus
profondément au niveau de la deuxième
couche de la peau le derme il s'attaque
à sa structure et à long terme ce sont
les principaux responsables de
vieillissement cutané et du
développement des cancers de la peau
donc peu importe la pigmentation il faut
se du soleil le peuple touareg l'a bien
compris malgré les fortes chaleurs du
désert il se couvre entièrement de
tissus à la maille serrée pour ne pas
laisser passer les UV en Égypte antique
on trouve aussi des papyrus qui font
déjà mention de produits destinés à la
protection solaire les crèmes solaires
que nous utilisons aujourd'hui ont vu le
jour au début du 20e siècle au Japon aux
États-Unis puis en France avec ce que
l'on appelait l'ombre solaire leur
utilisation a vraiment explosé avec les
premiers congés payés en 1936 les
premières vacances au bord de la mer
alors vous l'avez deviné les crèmes
solaires sont conçues pour empêcher les
rayons ultraviolets de pénétrer dans la
peau pour cela elle contiennent
différents types de filtres qui
absorbent ou repoussent le rayonnement
solaire
mais du coup 20 35 ans qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire c'est l'indice
SPF sunburn protection facteur le
facteur de protection solaire il indique
la capacité du produit à retarder
l'apparition d'un coup de soleil pour le
calculer on expose une petite surface de
proue d'un courage volontaire un
rayonnement ultraviolet une partie de
cette surface est recouverte de crème
l'autre nom et on mesure le temps qui
s'écoule jusqu'au moment où la peau
commence à rougir si le coup de soleil
apparaît au bout de 2 minutes sur la
peau nue alors qu'il n'apparaît au bout
d'une heure sur la surface protégée
l'indice de protection et de 30 car la
durée d'exposition avant l'apparition du
coup de soleil a été multipliée par 30
un indice de protection de 50 signifie
que le facteur de retardement a été
multiplié par 50 et 50 plus ça veut dire
quoi c'est ce qui est mentionné lorsque
l'indice de protection est supérieur à
60 2 minutes par exemple pour que la
peau rougit soit l'absence de protection
120 minutes deux heures ou plus avec la
protection pour autant aucun produit ne
peut permettre une protection totale
c'est pour cette raison qu'en Europe la
mention écran total a disparu des
emballages depuis 2006
50 ça devrait le faire bon il faut quand
même être très vigilant avec les crèmes
les tests sont réalisés dans des
conditions de laboratoire ils ne
prennent pas en compte tous les aspects
de la vie quotidienne une mauvaise
application la transpiration le
frottement des vêtements ou du sable sur
la peau la baignade bref on estime que
la protection est au moins réduite de
moitié par rapport au test réalisé en
laboratoire du coup quand vous lisez 30
pensez plutôt 15 c'est pour cette raison
qu'il est fortement conseillé de
renouveler l'application de la crème au
moins toutes les deux heures et après
chaque baignade bien reçu cette fois
j'ai mis la dose pour ta peau c'est très
bien pour l'environnement en revanche
c'est pas drôle du tout chaque année
près de 25000 tonnes de crème solaire se
dilue dans les mers et les océans deux
fois et demi le poids de la Tour Eiffel
or certains composés chimiques contenus
à l'intérieur peuvent perturber la faune
marine en particulier les coraux il
détruisent les larves du corail
perturbent leur reproduction et
provoquent leur blanchissement pour
lutter contre cette pollution certains
pays comme la Thaïlande Hawaï ou
l'archipel de Palaos dans le Pacifique
ont purement et simplement interdit les
crèmes solaires elle est plutôt toxique
à savoir celle qui contiennent de
l'occidentone de l'octocrinel et des
parabenes c'est composé sont présents
dans la plupart des crèmes vendues par
les grandes marques selon plusieurs
associations écologistes la crème 100%
biodégradable et sans impact sur
l'environnement n'existe pas encore en
fait pour se protéger la peau des
risques de coups de soleil et de cancer
cutanés sans polluer l'environnement et
bien il faut se couvrir avec des
vêtements légers même pour la baignade
comme ça
ça te va très bien de cette manière on
réduit les parties du corps à protéger
avec de la crème qui se limite au visage
aux oreilles aux avant-bras et aux
jambes enfin il est préférable de ne pas
s'exposer au soleil entre 10h et 16
heures et n'oubliez pas non plus le
chapeau
et les lunettes de soleil
voilà je suis sûr que maintenant vous en
connaissez un rayon sur les coups de
soleil je vous souhaite une excellente
semaine et à dimanche prochain waouh
il y a pas la peine de Noël
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]